[Music]
my next guest is a talented comedian
who's been seen in films such as the
hangover and the hangover part two
please welcome the very funny brody
stevens
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much i know
many of you are trying to figure out
where i was in the hangover
i was not the monkey i was not that
very hairy as a child true story very
hairy growing up most kids in my
neighborhood had flintstone vitamins
somehow i had rogaine chewables
i was on last comic standing i'm funny
last comic standing season four episode
one i was on there
you know i've got a bike now but i'm
saving up i'm gonna get a 1996 toyota
avalon yes
thank you
uh leather exterior
cruise control and reverse i love hip
hop a great sound system i love bow wow
and ludaris
you know i'm doing okay you know i was
in the hangovers hangover one in it
hangover two in it due date in it funny
people i got cut out of that
but i'm making money it's a good feeling
to be able to take my mother out to
lunch and pay half i can do
that a lot of people say brody you live
with your mother and i don't live with
my mother that's a lie i live with my
sister
in a condominium owned by my mother
uh i do work out i bench pressed 250
pounds today thank you
thank you uh at curves
her name is sheila she fell off the life
cycle
stay with me people i'm professional
booking things feeling good my sister
was abusive she beat me up true story
growing up she beat me up she spit on me
threw keys at me beat me with a pan and
you're saying brody what beatings hurt
the most the beatings with the keys yeah
why you asked because my sister was a
janitor
that's a lot of keys
go ahead with an applause break i'll
take it
why not
positive energy yes feeling good enjoy
that my mom loved the arts and crafts
children's parties the renaissance fair
after giving birth to me she had her
tubes tied into a balloon animal
if you hear laughs there join in over
there
let's get this thing going
i've done table reads on this lot
guys great news i booked another movie
uh it's an adult video out in chatsworth
doing a solo scene on a yoga mat
guys here's the deal i got 18 000 hits
on youtube today 18 000 hits yeah
uh i uploaded 19 000 videos
a lot of comments a lot of positivity uh
i'm not a part of the mile high club
that's
having sex in the airplane i am not you
think i would be but i'm not
not a part of the mile high club however
one time i exposed myself on a ferris
wheel
l.a county fair during the sugar ray
concert
saved it with a sugary reference yes
um guys i want to say you know uh
download your music legally i download
all my music legally but i stole my ipod
so
love music
i'm the house drummer at the guitar
center
yes
positive energy feeling good very
intense i get b.o in the shower
sensitive skin at night i wear moon
block
i do get girls i get i get chicks if you
will uh
i was just with a girl from greece thank
you uh the movie
she's 65 now
and we made out while watching cocoon
but you know it's not all glamour sure
i'm doing well i'm getting laughs many
of you are dvr'ing this it's positive uh
but i get lonely you know sometimes i go
down the batting cage
just to play catch
put my tokens in they make you wear a
helmet but
i got laughs i think i i i might hook up
tonight a lot of women say i like a guy
with a sense of humor and tonight i have
displayed that sense of humor
yes
yes
you know but
i don't think they're into me it's like
they want to they want to be with brad
pitt you know making love to brad pitt
well i'm on the corner of their bed
doing knock-knock jokes
be with me guys thank you very much i
had a great time
positive energy
yes
very funny thank you positive energy
positive energy yes
bernie siemens ladies and gentlemen